TONIGHT IN THEIR SECOND MEETING
AGAINST THE JETS IE CALLED FOR
THIS GAME ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS,
PLAYED IN THAT GAME LAST NIGHTFE
PIVOTS OUT FRONT
JUSTNG
STREAK
AND THEY HAVE SCORED JUST ONE
GOAL IN THEIR LAST TWOA GOAL AN
FIRST NHL GAME.
>> Bret: IT HAS BEEN A GOOD PA
9-3.
WHEELER WITH ONE ON NET.
ECKLUND POWER PLAY HAS BEEN ON
FIRE
IT IS AN IMPORTANT WEAPON FOR
EVERY TEAM IN THE K.
BURNS OVER TO THE LEFT SIDE.
MEIER LOOKS OFF ACK FOR HELP
TRIED TO HEAD MAN IT FOR CONNOR.
SHARKS
TIMO MEIER.
MEIER HAD A SIX-GAME POINT
STREAK SNAPPED HERE ON THURSDAY.
DILLON CHALLENGING BURNS, LETS U
PLAYN MORRISEY
HE FEEDS, AND THAT'S A AT PAR
POST
ALMOST IN LAYERS
AND OFF THE GOAL TENDER.
OR OFF TIMO ON HIS TAPE.
LOWRY WITH A GOOD BACK CHE NHL
TURN OVER BYDS
TRYING TO CUT TO THE PUCK.
THE SHARKS HAVE BEEN IMPRESSIVE.
YUT SHOOTING THEEND UP ON NET TO
HELLEBUYCK
AND HE'S ABLE TO PLAY IT
BUT GAVE IT RIGHT T F BALANCE.
OUT FRONT RIGHT THERE -- THAT'S.
DILLON, HE WILL SLOT IT BACK
CONNOR, GETSTHE ICE
BECAUSE HE'S A THIEF
THEY WILL COME UP FROM BEHE THED
CUTS HIM OFFR SCHMIDT.
HE HAS DUBOIS.
UP
THE REBOUND.
THEN THE HOTTEST GUY THIS THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE HAS
NOTHING LEFT TED IT AWAY TO THER
FINAL SECONDS.OVERTIME
A TURNOVER BY THE JETS RIGHT OFF
THE E MEIER WHEN HE IS
TIMO TIME IN OVERTIME, AND
TH